all right one of the things that we saw
last week with the 2021 draft some
reunions of college teammates most
notably and most significantly jamar
chase the fifth overall pick in the
draft a receiver from lsu who was great
with joe burrow in 2019 opted out for
2020 and the bengals at a time when
some believe they would go offensive
line to help protect joe burrow as he
recovers from that torn acl and take
penne sewell they went with jamar chase
so
shireen which college teammates reunited
thanks to the draft will have the
biggest impact and we can start there
because i would suspect we'd both agree
given the impact they had together at
lsu jamar chase and joe burrow assuming
borough is healthy could be a special
combination in cincinnati
absolutely that's where i would start
mike and you look what jamar chase did
in 2019 he was best receiver in football
84 catches 17 80 yards and 20 touchdowns
he was outstanding with joe burrow as
his quarterback and now they're reunited
in cincinnati and you look at that
receiving core all of a sudden
t higgins tyler boyd on tate and and now
jamar chase who they drafted to be their
new quarterback one i mean receiver one
to replace aj green this is a really
good receiving choir i'd like to see him
upgrade it tight end it's probably too
late to do that unless you
do some sort of trade or something but i
do like the receiving core and i think
he has a lot of weapons on offense
including the running backs there to
build around this could be a really good
offense this season mike
and you know something sims and i talked
about earlier today
the idea that
they went with an interior offensive
lineman top around two who could
eventually kick out the left tackle but
for this year particularly
when you when you look at the concern
that joe burrows gonna have like carson
palmer did in 2006 the first year post
acl tear when you're worried about that
plant leg
i would be more concerned about blocking
for joe burrow up the middle this year
so he has some security so he has some
confidence that that knee is not going
to get caved in again and then you can
develop that guy if you choose to into
the into the left tackle so yeah i think
there's going to be an incredible um
connection between chase and burro and
look if you can get you can either as i
said last week you can either draft a
guy that gives you more time to throw or
you can draft a guy that's going to get
open fast enough that you can get rid of
the ball more quickly that's what they
went with and i think that would be
great you know
the idea that the jaguars ended up with
both trevor lawrence and travis atn both
in the first round couple of clemson
guys now
urban meyer came out and said he really
wanted to get cadarius tony and travis
atn's got to wonder what the hell man i
mean you know
what how am i supposed to feel about the
fact that you wish someone else had been
on the board when you when you settled
for me
but we saw that clemson offense and
that's just you know it's it's just one
of those intriguing things college coach
who was wildly successful quarterback
and running back from a team that was
wildly successful does it translate to
the nfl we'll find out but if it does
it's going to have a lot to do with
lawrence and atn reunited in
jacksonville shireen
yeah i like that they come from a
winning program mike they were 39 and
three over the last three years we know
they won that national championship uh
in 2018 and he lost the national
championship in 2019 so this is a duo
who knows how to win they know how to
create yards they know how to create
points and i think this is going to be
really exciting for the fans in
jacksonville who have long wanted
something to cheer about again it's been
a long time since this team has been
this excited about a season and i think
they have all the right to be excited
about this team and building and the
future of the these jaguars in
jacksonville
apparently today tony khan the son of
owner shad khan said that tim tebow
will help the jaguars according to urban
meyer yeah the where it counts the most
this is ultimately a business and
they're selling tickets and they're
building legitimacy and the folks in
jacksonville are excited and what better
way to add to it the icing on the cake
local hero tim tebow joining the team is
a tight end it's just a matter of time
before it happens folks get get ready to
peel the minshew off the back of those
jerseys you can you can keep the w
and add a t-e-b-o
because 15 is gonna have a far different
meaning in 2021 than it ever has before
for the jaguar
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports